[Music]
the first thing we're gonna talk about
is something this is again something
Disney Plus is allowing Marvel Studios
to do for the first time our first
animated series called what if now what
if is based on a comic series that we've
loved for years where they take a
storyline you know and change one
element and see how things could get
different so the 23 films of the MCU
that you know we're going to showcase
one little difference in each episode
and see how things change Peggy Carter
herself Hayley Atwell
[Applause]
the Falcon in the Winter Soldier and I
would love you to meet our head writer
mile from Spelman and our director
Carrie Skagen
[Applause]
anthony mackie and so that
[Applause]
and I would also love to tell you
exclusively for d23 for the first time
Sharon Carter is returning miss Emily
VanCamp
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and a new character entering the MCU in
this series is a character named John
Walker and he's played by the great
Wyatt Russell
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the filmmakers in
the cast of the Falcon the Winter
Soldier coming to Disney Plus thank you
very much thank you thanks guys thank
you very much all right thank you thank
you
awesome we're doing it another series
we've announced it already it features
two of our most iconic Avengers Wanda
Maximoff and the vision Lizzy Olsen Paul
Bettany are starring in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
joining the cast reprising her role as
Darcy Lewis is kat dennings
[Applause]
reprising his role as agent Jimmy woo
from ant-man the wasp Randall Park
[Applause]
[Music]
the amazing Kathryn Hahn
[Music]
[Applause]
in a cast and the filmmakers of wand
division more to come thank you this
ping d23 it seemed like you might want
some new information and you might want
to hear about three new shows we're
doing for district 5
so let's reveal the first one miss
Marvel Camilla Kon Muslim Pakistani
teenager from Jersey City is coming to
the MCU it is remarkably exciting for us
you will meet her in her Disney Plus
series and then you will see her in our
films moon night a new action-adventure
series coming to Disney Plus a very
famous Marvel character for many years
marc spector he was a mercenary he was
left for dead in the Egyptian desert and
he now may or may not be infused with
powers from khonshu that moon God or he
might just be crazy it is something very
unique and exciting for us
she-hulk coming to Disney Plus Bruce
Banner is no longer the only Hulk in the
MCU Jennifer Walters is a Hulk she's a
lawyer and she's going to start a show
unlike anything we've done before this
is what Disney Plus is doing for the MCU
it is growing it is expanding it thank
you thank you so much that's what we've
got thank you so much everybody
appreciate it thank you